hey Mia in your previous jobs before
Google you worked with cicd right yeah
over the last five years I've built CI
CD pipelines with Jenkins Spinnaker
tecton and other tools very good when I
read online articles about cicd I see
many practices that seem like good ideas
but I'm not 100 sure what they all mean
and I don't know how to apply them all
to my serverless projects on Google
Cloud could we review them together
totally let's do it
foreign
[Music]
let's first talk about the CI in cicd it
stands for continuous integration I
believe and it sounds like a good idea
to integrate your software early and
often but what does this actually mean
so CI means that whenever a developers
commit code to Source control and
automatic build is triggered followed by
automatic test Suites so for example a
developer might accidentally check in
code that prevents the software from
being built and if that happens we want
to know right away that way we can fix
it quickly and avoid wasting other
developers time with an untestable
system
and you mentioned automatic test Suites
yeah so if the automatic build worked we
want automatic tests to run as well
usually that means running all the unit
tests and maybe some integration tests
as well and the build and test should be
automated to save developers time is
that the idea yeah but also to ensure
that they're done the same way every
time automation means that you get
reliably correct builds and it's a good
first step towards a more secure
software supply chain you can also read
more about secure software supply chain
best practices on the website salsa.dev
that's
slsa.dev sounds good I have a serverless
application hosted on Google Cloud run
how do I set up continuous integration
for it so continuous integration really
just means that we need a place to
execute builds and tests as part of a
workflow but setting that up manually
can be kind of a pain luckily Cloud
build can execute your builds for you
Cloud build lets you define a set of
build steps in a yaml file and configure
them to run when an event like a pull
request occurs okay great it sounds like
Cloud build would fit my needs where
should I start so here's a tutorial that
will guide you through that process it
gives a nice overview also take a look
at this repo it shows how to add a unit
test step to the cloud build
configuration file it also includes some
examples for common programming
languages all right I think I understand
continuous integration enough to start
using it in my project
but what about CD some people say it
means continuous delivery and others say
it means continuous deployment what's up
with that Mia so it can mean either one
continuous delivery means that automatic
builds are running and that the result
automatically gets deployed to an
internal test environment anybody can do
this continuous deployment on the other
hand means that once code is checked
into a certain Branch or some other
trigger the software is automatically
built tested and then if those tests
pass deployed to production where end
users can see it
deployed to production continuous
deployment sounds risky it can be but if
you have a really good test suite and a
strong testing culture in your
organization it can really improve
change velocity but I think it's fair to
say that most teams don't use continuous
deployment ah I've heard that continuous
integration is a must before you can
aspire to continuous delivery or
continuous deployment
so continuous deployment without
continuous integration is incredibly
risky it's really important that you
build confidence in your pipeline before
using it for continuous deployment all
right so how do I set up continuous
delivery or deployment for my cloud run
project so the first thing you want to
do is to make sure you're using a
separate Google Cloud project for your
test environment and for your production
environment and if you want continuous
delivery you can add a deployment step
in your Cloud build configuration file
so that your built software gets
deployed to your test environment
and if I want continuous deployment I
make that last step deployed to
production instead exactly but you
probably don't want all commits made by
developers to make it to production
right away you can set up a build
trigger to only kick off your Cloud
build config when code is committed to a
particular branch in Source control your
main branch might represent production
and you can merge code into that Branch
for deployments to production ah thank
you that gives me a way to get started
with CD my next question is about Canary
releases the concept is that you deploy
a new version of your software to only
some of your users to try it out before
you expose it to everybody I really like
the idea yeah me too so let's say you
have a new version of the web
application that has a bug in it that
was not caught by your automated tests
let's also say that you only rolled out
that new version to five percent of your
users hopefully at the slightly larger
five percent scale you'll hear from a
user about the unexpected Behavior or
you might notice errors in your logs and
because I did a five percent Canary
release only five percent of my users
ran into the bug if I done a regular
non-canal release a hundred percent of
my users would have been affected by the
bug right that's exactly right Canary
releases get their name from an old
method of testing mines for carbon
monoxide you can't smell or see that gas
but it can be deadly to miners a
Scottish doctor figured out that birds
are more sensitive to carbon monoxide
than people so he would bring a caged
bird into the mine with him oh and if
that bird stopped chirping it was time
to clear out that's right but it's
really important that you have a way of
noticing if that happens a canary
release should not hide errors but be
loud about them for example it could
display an error message to users or
page a site reliability engineer or even
write errors to your log and how long
should I run this Canary release that's
a really important thing to consider and
you want to give the canary release
enough time so that hard to find errors
reveal themselves this depends on the
application but it should be much longer
than a typical release stub the thing to
keep in mind is that the fewer users
that your application is exposed to the
longer it will take for issues to
surface
all right how do I set up Canary
releases for my cloud run service so
Cloud run has built-in traffic splitting
which makes this really easy you can set
the percentage of traffic going to each
revision of your service in the cloud
console you can also do this with the
gcloud command line client I've also
heard about revision specific URLs yeah
if you want to be extra careful you can
start by sending zero percent of your
production traffic to your new version
you can give your new version a special
URL so that only users who enter that
address get the new version then you can
let your developers or QA team or even
Early Access customers test it out
before you open it up to all of your
production users very good can't wait to
start using this for my applications you
know yeah so far I've been deploying my
apps by entering gcloud run deploy
manually from the command line and I
haven't used any of these techniques we
talked about and there's nothing wrong
with that but when your users start
demanding more from your applications a
robust CI CD pipelines and gonna help
you maintain your quality
thank you for these tips Amelia and
thank you everyone for watching you will
find links to the repos and tools we
talked about in the show notes if you
have questions for me or me or
suggestions for future serverless topics
please enter them in the comments below
we read every single comment until next
time
[Music]